still with us
audience of citizens in Southeast Sulawesi
the spread of it
Sexy TikTok video
who is suspected of being committed by
one of the government-owned bank employees
the said TikTok video
media viral on social media and causing a sensation among residents
from the results of the temporary identification search
the woman is suspected
is
an employee of one of the banks in the city of Baubau
the bank officials who met with the journalists said
will call and impose sanctions
because it is considered to have violated discipline
according to him,
the actions of that employee
has tarnished the good name of the company
and should not be done by employees.
Indeed,
where could that be?
he/she violates discipline and
we have rules regarding what kind of employees are allowed
the main thing is to let it out
what is there, sanctions sir
that definitely exists
If you violate,
there will be.
only that is possible to be accepted later
from this group
generally generally
the problem is the video